you know what you never see and it's
kind of weird
is investigative reporting about
teachers unions
some of the most corrupt institutions in
the country and definitely the most
powerful
teachers unions are the single reason
that millions of children maybe yours
aren't going to school and some of them
are dying it's not an overstatement
now teachers unions say that they can't
teach because it's unsafe
science doesn't back that up but nobody
calls them on it unless a teacher's
union executive
literally posts instagram photos from
the caribbean and that actually happened
in one case
no one covers it no one bothers to
report
on whether the unions are lying or not a
lot of journalists don't have kids so
they don't care
people who do have kids do care quite a
bit in berkeley california one group of
parents is doing what the media refuse
to do
they call themselves the gorilla moms
wish you could book them on the show to
congratulate them
but we don't know who they are because
they're anonymous just like many
politicians they fear retribution from
the teachers unions
but since march of last year the
guerrilla moms have heard from the head
of the local teachers union
matt meyer that school absolutely cannot
reopen
sorry can't teach your kids they're
going to languish at home online
so the gorilla moms decided to find out
what matt meyer was up to
they just posted a video online showing
matt meyer walking his
own child to a private preschool you're
seeing pictures of it now
meyer was caught hard to imagine
anything more hypocritical or offensive
but he didn't apologize he just said his
own kid
had no options quote they're not public
schools for kids her age
and that's true but it's true because of
people like matt meyer and because of
journalists who aren't anywhere near
as useful as a few anonymous moms with a
camera in california
whoever you are guerrilla moms god bless
you